when Mexico sends his people they're not
sending their best they're bringing
drugs they're bringing crime they're
rapists making me more excited to show
everyone that we can overcome this and
empower each other it's not fair and
it's not okay to generalize one group of
people everybody's entitled to to to
their freedom of speech and so you know
never wants to think about leaving it
was hard to hear because i am so
compassionate towards immigrants because
that is a part of my background I can't
control what's going on around me and
out there right now but what I can
control is my mind my body and my spirit
I'm gonna stay mentally and physically
focus other women here are so inspiring
we all come from so many different
places different backgrounds we pursue
different career paths and so we have so
much to learn from each other and so
much to talk about it's been a great
experience